holiday shopping is well underway we
want to make sure you're in the know
when it comes to the season's hottest
toys joining me is a
senior editor at ttpm that's toys tots
pets and more lori leahy
to give us a sneak peek now lori
las vegas loves its nascar and if you
have a younger fan of the sport it looks
like you've got the perfect gift
yes the team nascar crash circuit course
from far out toys is perfect for kids
who love racing ages 5 and up
it comes with some cars that only charge
up in 10 seconds or less
so it's really quick to get them out on
the 14 feet of track to race
and they do have breakaway parts so then
in case they crash
there's a little bit more racing action
going on there so this is going to be
great for young kids
or older kids who enjoy racing cars it's
about 49.99 yeah i actually am very
interested in that one
let's talk about beyblade what do you
have uh
the rise hypersphere that sounds kind of
cool
yeah so this is another way for kids to
have some battling
action it's the burst rise hyper sphere
from hasbro
uh so there are brand new of these
battling spinning tops for kids to
collect kids love kind of combining the
pieces from their different beyblades to
kind of create the ultimate beyblade and
with these
if you spin them in the new beyblade um
hypersphere
bay stadiums they will rise up the side
so it looks really really cool and just
again adds more to that action-packed
play and these are for ages eight and up
okay i love that i love the action but
then also we want to use
our minds too when it comes to playing
what toy do you have for that
so this one's great for kids and adults
it's roto brain from creative brain
works for ages eight and up
there are three levels to unlock and you
have to figure out which three color
combos
are going to unlock each level um it's
going to take you a while it's
definitely a
challenging brain teaser puzzle game if
you like those kinds of things
and the whole movement of it reminds me
of turning the dial on your high school
locker
if you if you remember that so it's just
it's that kind of moving and twisting it
and just
using your brain to figure out how to
unlock the puzzle so it's a lot of fun
that's like next level rubik's cube
time okay let's talk about something
that my little one loves
the lol surprise what do they have in
store for us this season
okay so brand new is the remix
collection
and this is a music themed collection of
dolls you've got the big dolls like i
have here you can purchase them
individually the small dolls they're
even pets
but what ultimate ella well fans will
want is the super surprise
from mga for ages five and up it's kind
of a big ticket item it's a huge box it
comes with
eight dolls and musical instruments that
play music
so if you love lol you are definitely
going to want to unbox
everything in this boombox themed
playset
um and the whole thing can actually kind
of become a concert stage or like a
backstage dressing room so there's a lot
of play going on in just this one
huge box so it's definitely worth it if
you love lol that is amazing i love it
okay from
from lol surprise to vip pets what do
you have for me right so
yeah we're going to finish it off a lot
of unboxings here um so vip pets is from
imc toys
and this is just a new way to collect
really cute uh pets
it's kind of like a hair salon
experience where you're kind of like
shampooing giving them a bath to unbox
the the pet that's inside and when you
do get that unboxed
there's this beautiful long hair so lots
of great creative hair styling with the
accessories
you can mix and match lots of different
pets to collect you're going to love
getting creative with these so these are
super cute for ages three and up that's
right i don't watch those 99 each and i
just i love the hairspray bottle too
it's so
clever that is so adorable yeah the
packaging is everything okay we only
have a few seconds left but what would a
holiday season be without
barbie i know so barbie from mattel
color reveal slumber party surprise
more than 50 things to unbox inside this
huge set so definitely if you're a
barbie fan
you love it you put the doll in the
water you reveal what the doll is it
kind of takes you through a slumber
party game to unbox all the accessories
and then you have a cool slumber party
themed playset and you can add all your
other barbies to it so it's a really fun
unboxing
experience for barbie fans ages three
and up thank you so much lori that's
quite a haul you can see
all of these toys at ttpm.com
las vegas now we'll be right back